speaking of the team that deliberately
may have two quarterbacks to the team
that deliberately put in its third
string quarterback on sunday night the
eagles have a real problem here and this
is going to resonate deep into the
postseason and possibly into 2021 and
possibly beyond it may require a hard
reset of the franchise before this one
goes away frankly players aren't happy
with what occurred on sunday night there
was a report from jeff mclean of the
philadelphia inquirer that two defensive
players were going to confront doug
peterson during the game after jalen
hurts was removed for nate sutfeld they
were stopped that jason kelsey the
starting center and another offensive
player actually did go to peterson
during the game with a what gives kind
of a message to him so we haven't heard
much from the players because the eagles
benefited no locker room after the game
no reporters in the locker room after
the game more accurately so you don't
get those raw reactions and emotions and
i think the quotes coming out of the
locker room would have been epic on
sunday night shireen here's miles
sanders eagles running back no question
two day
two days after the fact let's hear miles
sanders two days after the fact with his
thoughts on what happened on sunday
night
miles the decision to take jalen out
obviously has come under great scrutiny
locally and nationally
um the conversations amongst your
teammates i mean how do how do the guys
feel
um
man
if i'm being honest if i'm being honest
no nobody liked the decision no fighting
and that's that's all i could say
really but um i don't know what was the
who was the main person behind that
decision but um all that all i know is a
lot of people on the team was confused
he thought for a second or two about not
going there but then he realized the
hell with it everybody knows everybody
knows that the players were upset and i
thought that was great for i'm surprised
he even did it but it just shows you
they can't now the season's over they
can't they can't muzzle these guys if
they want to talk they're going to talk
and the failure here shireen in my
opinion was
that if they were going
to to lay down in this game they needed
to do a better job of signaling it to
everyone ahead of time make nate felt
the starter in that game that would have
been a better signal a point sims made
today on pft live when jim schwartz
comes out and says this is a no hat no
t-shirt game for us that says that
they're trying to win and maybe in
hindsight it was a middle finger by
schwartz who's walking away from the
eagles after this season and he's smart
enough to come up with something like
that where the message is going to get
through that hey we're trying to win
when they really weren't but the bottom
line is doug peterson failed and the
eagles organization failed to let people
inside or outside properly brace for
what ultimately happened
sound like the quarterbacks knew mike
and not many other players knew so it
obviously wasn't communicated well
but it doesn't matter what you think it
doesn't matter what i think about the
decision it doesn't matter what anyone
outside that locker room thinks it
doesn't matter what joe judge thinks all
that matters is what those players think
inside that locker room and we've heard
we've heard from miles sanders we've
heard the inside reports on how eagles
players feel about this this is a dark
cloud over this organization and they've
got a lot of repair work to do once they
come back into that building mike
because it's it's obvious that players
did not agree with this uh situation and
what doug peterson did or whoever made
the decision i i think it was probably
above doug peterson but whoever made the
decision
and i think that the repair work should
be happening now this isn't something
that should sit until april i remember
six years ago when the seahawks lost in
super bowl 49 on that fateful decision
to throw instead of run and the players
were up in arms about it you had some
players like bruce irvin immediately
speaking out about it and it was clear
that the players were upset i remember
pete carroll going on the today show and
i'm thinking why is he on the today show
well this is one way to communicate your
message because to the extent that you
have other family members of these
players who are watching the today show
and they see it and they understand
where pete carroll is coming from you
get other people in the family working
on you in a positive way to get you to
understand why i did what he did and i
think the eagles need to be plotting out
some sort of broader media strategy here
take but but see here's the problem
here's the problem they can never say
that they were trying to lose the game
the minute they do that is the minute
the nfl descends on
the eagles the way they descended on the
patriots for spygate one two and three
the way and deflategate and the way they
descended on the saints for bounty gate
you can't come out and say it the league
isn't going to do anything to you as
long as you keep your mouth shut that
you were trying to lose the minute you
say you were trying to lose you're dead
so i don't know what they can do here
shireen
yeah it's exactly right mike and they
went from ninth overall pick two to six
so we're all picked by losing and and i
i get it everybody get it gets it i
think why they did it but you know i
keep going back to travis kelsey's
comments from the middle of december and
even if you're out of it you play to win
and here's the reasons why you and it
was a great speech that he made
but
doug peterson and what that organization
did during that game basically spit in
the face of everything that travis
kelsey said uh in the middle of december
and so i don't know how you resolve that
with travis kelsey or other players
within that locker room because you said
they can't admit it so i'm not sure how
you do this repair work uh that the
seahawks were able to do and pete
carroll was able to do uh in the super
bowl when marshawn lynch didn't get the
ball and everyone on that team thought
marshawn lynch should have gotten the
ball
yeah because the problem is if you admit
it to enough players it's going to get
out that they're admitting it and that
could be enough to activate the league
office's disciplinary arm and you know
other teams in week 17 played to win
when it was in their best interest long
term to not play to win the vikings it
was in their best interest to lay down
against the lions it was in the lion's
best interest to lay down although the
interim coach doesn't care because he's
not going to be there anyway but there
are other examples of teams where you
could look at and say what like the
49ers i mean they were they tried to
beat the seahawks they don't benefit
from beating the seahawks kyle shanahan
is definitely going to be there next
year but teams played to win
in lesser platforms than that game
number 256 which has a a special vibe to
it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports